russian-backed the government forces
have intensified their bombing campaign
which includes airstrikes dropping
barrel bombs and shelling the town of
Maarat al-numan in southern Italy
Syrians living there say the attacks are
indiscriminate
with hospitals markets and Homs targeted
here rescue workers are struggling to
save a young girl stuck under the rubble
of a home in marital nerman the town in
Northwest Syria is seeing some of the
heaviest attacks in the almost 9000
public anger against the offensive
spilled onto the streets on Friday
hundreds in Italy protested what they
called the neglect of their plight by
the international community they also
called for swift halt to the bombardment
we are the people of South a blurred
countryside we're out in a protest in a
blip city condemning the bombardment and
the targeting of the evacuees they tried
to flee their homes and the protesters
warned the match of the Friday prayers
in the small town of Samara
just a few kilometers from the border
with Turkey the town is a hub for aid
going into Syria fighters from the
opposition haya haya sham set up
barriers to stop the protesters from
walking towards the border but they
failed Turkish security forces say they
were forced to send reinforcements to
ensure the protesters didn't cross the
border with the intensified bombing
campaign forcing thousands to flee their
homes in Italy many faiths are cold and
hungry winter
official comes on the syria-turkey
border of food forcing many of the
displaced to live in flooded my shift
comes where a deliveries are few and far
between we're warming up using these
pieces of cloth this family consists of
16 people nobody helped us we use all
kinds of materials including shoes in
the stove to warm up our children fuel
prices have more than doubled in the
past two months and charities and
hospitals say they're struggling to
respond to the crisis Mohammed Al
Jazeera Istanbul